Let's discuss a couple of more complex things
that we want to do. We may not always want
to pull thousands of rows, or even the first 20 rows in order. Maybe we want a
specific subset of our data. For example, maybe
we're interested in all data corresponding to the state
Gujarat. In order to do that, we'd simply write,
select star from aadhaar_data, where state equals Gujarat. Note
that to limit our results, the where clause needs to go directly after the
table name. SQL syntax really does mirror the way we might say things out
loud very closely. Now, let's see what happens if we run this command. And
there you see, we have all the data where the state is equal to Gujarat.